well they finally did it guys we talked
about them possibly removing the dislike
button but it looks like youtube has
officially decided that starting today
the dislike count is completely removed
you no longer have the ability to see
how disliked a video is this has to be
one of the most unpopular moves youtube
has made in a while but ironically we
don't know exactly how unpopular it is
now let's bring down the board and show
you exactly what they said to know
exactly what their plan is team youtube
to reduce targeted dislike attacks and
their impact on creators especially on
smaller creators
like youtube cares about smaller
creators you'll no longer see a public
dislike count on youtube starting today
the dislike button is staying guys you
can smash it it just doesn't do anything
this comes after lots of research
testing and consideration now we're
going to watch this video together but
let me say up front i think this is a
pretty calculated way to kind of just
maximize views listen guys there's no
longer such a thing as a a bad take or a
bad person we're letting the entire
world upload but there's nobody bad on
this platform it's all positivity all
the time and you know what you get when
you get more positivity more ads more
purchases more sales guys give it up for
the advertising side of youtube they're
about to see a little bump i think
that's where the research team um did
the most homework but we're also going
to take them seriously on this idea of
it's all to help smaller creators gonna
give that a shot too so let's pull up uh
this video this is hosted by matt koval
don't harass him he's a nice guy i think
he just uh sort of a shoot the messenger
kind of situation they they shove the
nicest guy they have out there to give
us the bad news let's watch together hey
folks you may have seen a while back
that youtube announced it was
experimenting with making dislike counts
private to only the creator of the video
now if you're like me you were surprised
by that i mean i've always thought
seeing the number of dislikes on a video
helps us know as viewers if it's a good
video or not if it's a helpful tutorial
or not or if what a creator is is saying
in their video is generally agreed with
or not that is what the dislike button
is for okay to be clear remember what he
just said actually i'm glad he brought
this up the dislike button is so at a
glance because this is a social network
where anybody can upload you know at a
glance should i be watching this video
is it good is it agreed with what does
the community think that's what the
dislike button is great at doing so he
says that right up front and he says
look this is i thought this is what it
was for and then get ready for the
gaslight guys here we go but
unfortunately research teams at youtube
have found there's this whole other use
for disliking a video that i had never
experienced as a creator and you may not
have either
apparently groups of viewers are
targeting a video's dislike button to
drive up the count turning it into
something like a a game with a visible
scoreboard
and it's usually just because they don't
like the creator or what they stand for
okay so now we're told there's this
other side to dislike buttons and this
is definitely true right this is we all
know this is true but sometimes this is
to do what he said at the beginning
which is to show that people don't agree
with what that person
is saying and i think they should have
the ability to do that or they say look
it's a way of saying this creator has
done terrible things in the past we
don't like them now youtube's gonna say
look we need to protect creators and
that's fair enough that's why you have
the ability to turn off the like to
dislike ratio ladies and gentlemen
this is a problem that has already been
solved but youtube says they've looked
into this and there's a big problem here
team youtube says this was already an
option for creators but we've seen that
when creators choose to turn off likes
dislikes they can be bullied and
harassed for their decision ultimately
it's youtube's responsibility to protect
its community so we've made this change
across all videos so if we just make
everyone not have dislikes no one will
know the people who are choosing to hide
the descent now this is really stupid
and i'm going to explain why you could
make the exact same argument for
comments right comments are another
common way people express that they do
not like what is being said or they do
not like the video creators have the
ability to turn off their comments and
when they turn off their comments they
are frequently um harassed or made fun
of for hiding descent again so is
youtube's response to that going to be
to remove all comments because of the
fact that a few creators who are trying
to remove the comment section are
getting harassed for doing so is that
their response to all problems is that
if anyone ever gets harassed or bullied
or there are negative comments we must
remove it totally from the platform
because if that's the case comments are
next boys comments are next because
again creators you could just replace
likes to dislikes with comments here
creators choose to turn off comments
they can be bullied and harassed for
their decision ultimately we've made the
decision to remove this completely right
this is the exact same thing for
comments so it makes no sense you've
already built a way for creators to
remove likes and dislikes and comments
you're now just saying well the audience
can't know whether the creator is trying
to hide anything now we've got to give
them the ability to hide that they're
hiding and that comes per the crack team
of researchers at youtube their research
we're going to get into that because
this is where i absolutely lost my mind
so earlier in 2021 youtube experimented
with making the public dislike count
private to see if it would help reduce
these coordinated dislike attacks across
the platform
and after analysis they did see a
reduction wow the crack team of
researchers at youtube found that when
they removed the dislike count people
didn't bother to dislike the video
incredible stuff let's see what else the
research team found so the update from
youtube is that the dislike button is
staying but the dislike counts will now
be private
you can still dislike videos and that
action will be used to tune your own
recommendations but you won't be able to
see the dislike count
only the creator can find it on the back
end if they want
now a few common questions we saw from
the initial experiment
first without a public dislike count how
can viewers tell if a video is worth
watching again i kind of have this
question too but it turns out that while
viewers might use the dislike count to
give them a sense of a video's worth
when the teams looked at the data across
millions of viewers and videos in the
experiment they didn't see a noticeable
difference in viewership cap okay i'm
gonna call cap on that one i was all
with your uh team of genius researchers
up until this moment what this think
about what this manager said this is
such garbage okay what they're saying is
that if you see a ton of dislikes
everyone just watches the video again
still okay that's because people react
to dislikes differently given the video
here's the thing that drives me the most
crazy is the best use of the dislike
button is for things like tutorials and
things like where you're not sure of a
video's quality if i see that it's like
a very high dislike ratio i just click
off because i just know it's oh it's not
useful right to the mass amount of
people i have like a windows bug right
because windows is complete trash and i
go try to find a solution if i click on
it and there's a huge dislike ratio i
know i don't have to waste my time now i
don't even know that anymore what their
researchers are seeing i could have told
you which is that for popular creators
for big creators if there's a high
dislike ratio people end up usually
watching because they want to know what
the controversy was but that's not the
only reason people use dislikes as a
measure of like whether a video should
be watched or not this is so frustrating
because i know what happened in their
big experiment the biggest creators with
the most dislikes carried the data right
whereas the tutorial watching stuff like
that where people use dislikes as a
measure of should i watch the video or
not is this going to be useful or not
just got i guess discounted by this
whole team of researchers this is
absolutely wrong and the fact that
youtube is trying to pretend well our
researchers looked into it and there's
there's nothing in the data shows me
they aren't looking they maybe had a
pre-existing you know decision that
that's what they were going to do and
they decided they're going to find the
data and torture the data until they
prove it right there's no way you can
tell me that a highly disliked video if
it's a tutorial or something of that
nature is going to be watched the same
as something with like 100 likes it's
absolutely not true and it pisses me off
that we're just supposed to believe the
internal research of youtube ah guys
just believe it did you publish it
believe it hey we we did the research we
know what's best it's such a weird gas
light for you to be like well look we
looked into it i know this is unpopular
with like all our creators but we're
gonna remove the dislike so
so you can't even tell how unpopular it
is
this is where they really lost me with
this uh research team regardless of
whether they could
see the dislike count or not in other
words it didn't really matter if a video
had a lot of dislikes or not they still
watched next common question if creators
can still see the dislike count on the
back end how's that any different they
can see it if they look for it inside
studio analytics under the engagement
tab but overall it's much less likely to
cause stress and embarrassment if the
count isn't visible to the public again
to react to this real quick
sometimes
stress and embarrassment is okay listen
i'm not saying that creator harassment
is fine or whatever but if you do
something genuinely bad you should have
to face some sight
kind of consequence for that from your
audience right otherwise this isn't a
social platform it it's a uh backpacking
platform right because basically what
they're saying is your feedback is only
wanted
if it's positive we have no room anymore
on youtube for negative things and what
always kills me about this stuff is
platforms like this they they understand
that positivity sells better than
negativity so they want to they have an
incentive to encourage only positivity
but the funny thing is is encouraging
positivity doesn't end bad things
discouraging calling out bad things
doesn't breed more good things in fact
it just gives people cover to do the bad
things and not face any kind of
accountability you know it's funny
youtube wants to be able to decide who
and who cannot post on their platform
right they have their own guides
guidelines etc but the second that a
community itself says hey we don't like
this thing youtube has to come and step
in and go whoa whoa whoa guys we gotta
make this a safe space for everybody
while also deciding who can and cannot
post on their platform this seems to me
to be the opposite of like a hey
broadcast yourself mentality if it truly
is a social platform you should have the
platform
let people post and then the audience
react to the postings but they seem to
want to control everything which they're
doing a terrible job of because this is
the thing that really set me off because
obviously i didn't want to make this all
about what i do but obviously one of the
big things this is going to affect is
how many people scam and get away with
it right because there's going to be no
way for an audience to signal hey this
this is bad this is a bad video this is
a scam this is whatever as this person
says it uh robux scam streams fortnite
scam streams life scam streams lol
hiding dislikes is a nightmare youtube
comes in says big sigh
scams are not allowed on youtube so this
isn't the experience we want you or
anyone to have
well guys uh that's it for scams
say goodbye uh all the scammers don't
worry youtube doesn't want you other
platform that's clearly gonna do
something guys there's never been more
crypto scams influencer scams out there
than now i literally don't have time for
it but youtube's coming in here and
saying don't worry guys we'll find the
scams like no you won't continuously
people find new scams getting through
and clearly they let scams through
because some of the biggest influencers
on their platform did it just a few
months ago so this idea is so
condescending big sigh
scams are not allowed on youtube well i
don't know what to say scams are
thriving more than ever that's
hate to tell you that youtube and again
not to make this all about like scams or
what i do i i think it's bad sort of
across the board but scams are an
example of like legit bad behavior that
you want creators to face account
accountability for and clearly youtube
is trying to make it so that no one ever
has to face any accountability or any
dislikes already creators have the
ability to like not only turn off
comments but now they can um and this
has sort of been the case for a while
they can hide certain comments they like
they just remove them and youtube has
made the comment algorithm more and more
hiding and suppressing negative comments
and bringing bringing up all the
positive ones so more and more the
comment section is a giant circle jerk
anyway the dislike button was like the
last bastion of like well if you had it
on there's no way to fake it it just is
what it is you can't hide it you can't
remove dislikes the way you can comments
um and so i think you're gonna see more
and more creators just sort of getting
away with bad behavior and there's
nothing anyone could do to stop them but
don't worry guys it's all for your
safety your protection youtube is here
to help you out i can't imagine
something less popular that youtube is
more sure about with their crack team of
researchers i think it's um completely
insane i i hope they reverse this
decision and realize that creators who
are suffering from this
a may have done something bad right
that's one but b if it's just because
they have an unpopular opinion or
whatever and you want to include that on
your platform i think that's totally
legitimate just let them hide the
dislike button themselves this was not a
problem that needed a solution we
already had a solution and youtube's
answer is well they got shamed for it if
that's the case we're removing things
that people get shamed for you also have
to remove comments because comments also
have a thing where if someone disables
comments they also get hate for that so
the way i see this this was a solution
for no one and just sort of makes the
community less social less interesting
less informative frankly now it's more
like watching a netflix video but um i'm
sure that's what youtube wants because
it brings in more advertisers more bucks
for the big guys upstairs hopefully they
changed their mind but given youtube's
sort of history with this and the fact
they told us a long time ago everyone
hated it and they still did it i don't
think that's going to change all right
well pump the stock guys because you
can't do anything else thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one
try your best
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling